una forma de calcular el trabajo
realizado es usar la fórmula f x de
coseno de teta pero este número de la
cantidad de trabajo realizado representa
la cantidad de energía transferida a un
objeto por ejemplo si encontramos el
trabajo realizado y obtenemos 200 jours
positivos significa que la fuerza le dio
energía al objeto unos 200 dulce de
energía así que si tenemos una forma de
determinar la cantidad de energía que
algo gana o pierde
tendremos una forma alternativa de
encontrar el trabajo realizado ya que el
trabajo es la cantidad de energía
transferida a un objeto la energía que
gana o que pierde por ejemplo imaginen
un patinador de 50 kilogramos que
comienza en reposo si una fuerza hace
que este patinador se mueva a 10 metros
por segundo esa fuerza realizó trabajo
sobre el patinador ya que le proporcionó
energía a este la cantidad de energía
cinética que ganó el patinador
2500 jules lo que significa que el
trabajo realizado en el patinador fue de
2500 dispositivos es positivo porque la
fuerza en el patinador le dio al
patinador 2500 jours si la fuerza
proporciona energía a un objeto entonces
la fuerza realiza trabajo positivo en
ese objeto si la fuerza quita energía a
un objeto entonces la fuerza realiza
trabajo negativo en ese objeto ahora
imaginemos que el patinador que se está
moviendo a 10 metros por segundo se
detiene abruptamente porque choca con un
muro este muro de ladrillos va a
realizar un trabajo negativo en el
patinador porque le está quitando
energía para encontrar el trabajo
realizado por los ladrillos
tenemos que encontrar cuál es la energía
que el muro le quitó al patinador y ya
que el patinador comenzó con 2500 jules
de energía cinética y termina con 0
jules de energía cinética significa que
el trabajo realizado por los ladrillos
fue
- 2500 jules es negativo porque estos
ladrillos le quitaron energía al
patinador ahora digamos que vamos a
levantar estos ladrillos que tienen una
masa de 500 kilogramos hacia arriba 4
metros para encontrar el trabajo que
hemos realizado en los ladrillos
podríamos usar la fórmula de doble o
igual a efe por deco seno de teta pero
no es necesario podemos encontrar la
cantidad de energía proporcionada a los
ladrillos aquí los ladrillos han ganado
energía ganaron energía potencial
gravitacional que está dada por la
fórmula m por g por h si resolvemos esto
encontramos que los ladrillos ganaron
una energía potencial gravitacional de
19.600 jules significa que el trabajo
que realizaste en los ladrillos es de
19.602 positivos y son positivos porque
nuestra fuerza le dio energía a los
ladrillos esta idea no sólo funciona con
la energía potencial gravitacional y con
él
y a cinética funciona para cualquier
tipo de energía siempre podremos
encontrar el trabajo realizado por una
fuerza sobre un objeto si podemos
determinar la energía que la fuerza
proporciona o quita a dicho objeto